Rob handler e we are playing a journey
to the savage planet this is a game that
I checked out at PAX West a couple
months ago and I thought it was
hilarious a lot of fun the co-op in
particular struck me is quite
interesting
mmm so here we are you know nothing
about this game not are you in here
because knowing the kind of games you
like I figured you probably enjoy this
game but here we are we got to repair
our ship we're gonna see where this
adventure takes us yeah a little crash
land here ow
I can shoot you that's fun that is fun
right
let's keep that to a minimal I like the
I like the art style so far oh there now
okay cool we can shoot the stuff yeah
that feels nice oh no I did homicide ooh
ooh this G can we go there yeah at some
point wow this is a pretty big planet
nice music Oh journey to the savage but
I keep calling a journey to us savage
where'd you go okay
get close to this thing this plant yeah
I'm feeling this let's play is gonna be
you trying to yeah some good stuff bro
savage savage man alright so what what's
on our list of things to do here find
the alien no Allen alloy it's close yeah
so you can look at the compass up top we
can kind of follow that for now okay
there's a little animals you can kick oh
yeah check this out oh look you liked it
oh I think he's dead we got some carbon
out of it oh but yeah so in this game
you're you crash land on a strange
planet and you have to try to get off oh
it is alien oh oh oh
these guys don't look friendly yeah a
little bit of combat now okay
Inc on my screen my visor so these
things here mmm
oh that's good you just shove that right
into your visor and it doesn't really
look like you hate it oh there's none
left
thanks for sharing I think we share it
so now we're I'm gonna take the high
road
I threw bait on your head and it's just
still there oh my god knock it off I
guess I'll go first right let him out ya
know I got some new freaks out oh it
looks like the debate disappeared yeah
okay that's fine hey guys juicy loot
gross more like juicy fruit or did you
kick and then shoot it yeah that was
cool as [ __ ] there's a challenge for it
to it you must you must be a local
that's fun oh it's right
yeah I kind of missed I missed I try
another time
oh is that sound like a like a monster I
am really liking the spring animation
yeah all right it's not even a punch
you're just slapping it's just pitch
laughing yeah Oh a new animal boats can
it oh I can do this scan scan scan oh
whoa it turned into something else
divide it into three
oh I'm holding something different now
this isn't a canister always is this
like natural grub or something the
canisters no this is so throw it an
enemy they'll here look I try to move Oh
saw them down these things are like
mostly peaceful but we just show up like
the dodo bird of this planet that's cool
a little natural flashlight fun ok yeah
I'll take that way yeah I got aluminum
but you're right yeah we need that
flashlight looks like some sort of
ancient civilization has been here a
shrine of sorts can't leave any alive
now
you're jumping noise almost sounds like
you're saying nope
no no no so I picked the dog avatar on
my other game and I just go oh oh oh'
return god you don't look like a dog do
you know I still look like this is
what's the dog gonna get a helmet I
guess that's a little jump there worked
out what the hell I was trying to shoot
in the air you jumped in front of me huh
alright right here a jump pack one bar
of health now yeah that was not on
purpose
he's back pack yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
now we make these jumps great whoa
you're happy for a second there oh all
right we're good we're good
now land on these trees I can't no need
him you make it without it uh I like it
I think I think you did that's awesome
all right I guess we can do it or we're
just kind of exploring say oh this might
happen yeah
I want to do it I want to do it looks
like a booger okay hold still
yeah whoa all we saw always saw these
earlier oh that's that's clutch oh
[Music]
there's a teleport over here all right
[Laughter]
it's like some sort of asteroid landed
here what's this about
whoa Wow that hurt a lot
oh it's this what is that oh really
health well there's something going on
over here what is this thing guys you
died what is it is this these things
were shooting you yeah yeah they shoot
out like needles or something they
totally do they're just really small
needles want to see it Oh another guy
out oh he's pissed
oh whoa he's got some moves
you want to shoot its tail
Oh what now yeah okay oh god I got a
good help he's coming after you
dude he's real fast oh he loves come on
stick him to the ground
oh right oh he hates it throw your tail
I stopped shooting oh I thought he's
dead Oh stuck them
all right he looks that
oh my god
Oh show me your tail
[Music]
now okay I'm incapacitated you're on
your own
captain robbed cat died right here
I'm coming there those guys are pretty
tricky that let's spin roll move oh man
yet
the Dodge is pretty clutch oh right I
forgot to have that yeah
there we go okay yeah I got the last
kill what don't trust you at all that
was rough good lord those things are
brutal
I wasn't like I was not even that close
there's I thought in my wisdom I was
like I'm just gonna make this thing blow
up so I kicked one of the bulbs to it
they all just explode
600 always a help oh my god
oh it survived it - it didn't even work
oh nice cool alright that was all
intentional distraction oh good we I
didn't know you could pick you to the
wreck up we should have been doing that
a while ago
oops alright that was an accident
whoa what's that watch out oh we should
scan it first yeah that's too far away
just keep just keep distracting it
straight oh oh it's a boomerang it's
just straight up
[Music]
he's like kind of like pods or whatever
Oh Oh God yes so they're brutal
these things you can grab and throw and
they blow up
Oh No blew up this door okay cool
oh god the double jump sometimes Oh nah
I should be dead but that lava I didn't
know they were lowering platform yeah
give me some of this oh I feel like I'm
just just behind on some of these my
phone right away you are but we got to
blow up blow open that door over there
you see the one on next to ya
what oh wow it's a boomerang God where
is this damn boomerang I can't see it
Oh God wait a second did you throw that
oh my god you actually got me nope
that's not gonna work out I'm below the
rock again I'm up here on your own
that day you gotta give me no don't do
it you're gonna die alright I try that
again
proton tether sick so now like these
things oh the one I almost didn't make
oh that's cool
this kind of feels like yeah I figured
it was gonna be impostor you know it's
just like the lots of health packs a
bunch of circular platform Oh God
where's where's his weak spots I'll let
you figure that out [ __ ] don't make it
too easy okay has three little tentacles
on top oh yeah jump over that stuff oh
and crouch on that one okay that's one
there is help done much easier to people
oh he's on me
no that's gonna hurt huh oh no he's got
a lot more
jump oh no I'm okay I'm okay
oh no I'm not just finish them
you got it
nice nice work scan that [ __ ]
the Krag cloth anyway then I turn II to
the savage planet hope you had some fun
it is a it is a fun game especially with
with a buddy you can you can get up to
some trouble yeah I'm totally digging it
this seems like a good co-op experience
I like the pacing of it you know it's
like consistently entertaining for the
most part so yeah thanks for showing me
this yeah of course and make sure to
check out our review which should be
going up sometime soon
cool sweet thanks Jake bye